Hammond's I have no music no poetry you
know sandwiches I'm going to talk about
our quest for the perfect metric we are
a young organization and at that moment
of vulnerability insecurity where we are
trying to measure a lot of stuff this is
the stuff we are trying to measure
everything from operational
effectiveness to the effectiveness of
our engagement with our nation partners
to what they do after our engagement to
how readers react to what they do
buh-buh-bah on and on down the rabbit
hole I've become very popular with our
staff every time I mention the word
metrics they you know cheer and jump up
with excitement it's it's a it's a happy
moment for us all so why do we do this
well we do this in part because you know
obviously this creates value for for our
constituents for our newsroom partners
we learn from from the feedback we get
from from these metrics we are trying to
to improve everything we do and this is
important for for the news business and
yes this to to be fair our funders
especially nany Cano at gates have been
incredibly important in helping us frame
metrics as a way to to firm firm
strategy but this is our magic question
does solutions journalism what we are
trying to build the frame change we're
trying to do actually do something for
for engagement we know from research
that negative news drives drives readers
away what does positive news do so to
start we had to have to describe what is
solution journalism in the first place
we came up to ten normal questions there
actually nine here so you won't be
tested on the tenth and Bryan Abelson
who I think is here Knight Mozilla
fellow developed this cool app to help
us code stories for solution enos and we
will pay for a better word than solution
eNOS so our pilot project with the
Seattle Times allowed us to to code
stories Sonia song another members OA
fellow came up with this incredible
analysis one one finding was David
Bornstein the co-founder and
I had a 80% correlation for what
solutionist meant which meant that we
have to start taking separate vacations
about what my next slide is gonna be
let's wait for a second here
so the we are testing this now in fact
my I have my phone because damn it Janet
USC may call it any minute with the
findings but we have some anecdotal
evidence that says yes solution the
stories drive traffic but we can't tell
from one solution story to the next
solution in us which is which is more
important there is too much noise
likewise we're working on Lyndsey green
barber to use try her impact tracker to
record anecdotal evidence at impact from
stories how many people email what they
say in the email is their policy change
is their discussion this is the sort of
data we're getting and again incredibly
useful incredibly important to
journalists but hard to get a handle
again on this core question of doesn't
make a difference when you put solutions
content into a story so real life is
hard we decided to pull back and get
away from real life and do sort of a
laboratory experiment which meant
comparing a solution sorry two versions
of the same story three stories on on
clothing in India homelessness violence
and education one rooted in the problem
the other the same problem content but
adding in solutions content we sent the
story two random versions of the story
to 755 respondents and this is what they
said significantly higher reactions to
the question have you gained new
knowledge are you better informed are
you more interested in this in this
story also higher engagement reactions
yes more likely to share the article
with friends more likely to talk about
it with friends friends and family more
likely to read more more stories in the
paper or magazine and in fact higher
engagement with the issue in a society
that says I'm more likely to get
involved with an organization involved
in this issue more like likely to donate
and more likely to to engage in the
issue so there was much cheering when
these came out suddenly our staff is is
is incredibly excited about metrics and
and is begging me to participate in
these projects literally and that's it
our finding for now is that there there
does seem to be some correlation between
solutions content and engagement and
there's where we go from here thank you
[Applause]